coup d'oeil c'est normal les personnes
âgées des relations naturellement c'est
normal c'est plus que normal c'est
naturel qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
répondre aux demandes sept partenaires
bah on chez en brèche proches et bien on
fait ce qu'on peut et les gens qui
trouve ça un peu indécent qu'on n'aille
pas au cul
quand je trouve qu'il ya tellement de
changements à c'est à dire le lieu où on
essaye de le voir mais on cherche un peu
quand même mais quand il arrive alors là
ça fait mal mon rôle c'est mon voeu le
faire tu le fais plus en ont envie
est-ce que vous vous sentez plus hardis
aujourd'hui vous qui attend allons quand
même pas ma faim toutes les occasions
que je peux avoir moi j'ai loupé à
convoyer un bel homme dans la rue sauf
en effet hop je dirais bien j'aimerais
mieux qu'ils tombent molik le tonnerre
mais c'est tout mais si je vois un
silbande loge de metz quand même et se
régale la ville a même pas dégueulasse
il faut en profiter encore des jeunes